hello good Roni good evening ladies Joe
hello everybody everybody's hurting good
day good
every today is Holden from Bolton
reviews FMA at least they admit that
there's guns no snapping fingers going
firewall current from the animism that
it had been canceled for this one day
and I was like what is this news
broadcast that they put over my anime
and it turns out to be 9/11 is our kata
from glass reflection Jing Jing Zhi Shan
do you even Jean anymore its kind so
cause he's so strict and like I
understand his ways and like and I just
like he's like bed go group I'm Jean
from excess of genes singers it's like
pulled aside on scheduling okay
everything that you're doing and come
off I just made it so a lot worse pain
and we have um butter Scotch from
butterscotch Aziz oh hello ladies how's
it going the quiet ones tend to be the
kinky ones that we know it's my husband
really that preventive a man Connor
Connor Connor just go to just go to bed
with like your door or something
we have Paulo from Baca shifts someone
had cracked awake alone in the morning
just as I make that [ __ ] realization
why here's someone walk in the room
behind us Sarah from 40 to believer [ __ ]
the first season in the a movie panel
yeah we move she petted Kyocera
so do the bikes have seats or is it just
the thing was I just hop a [ __ ] okay
[ __ ] feet either college with the
words always happen we got my man
Kenneth Pulido ah blah blah blah blah
Black Butler blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah
we have suing from sikhnet guys watch it
so um we now know that suing is hi guys
this is shoe man Jimmy from our my
editorial you know when you're on the
club and you see a really fat girl you
look at her and she's kind of got a cute
face I'm thinking to myself nah my mom
telemundo me whoa I really I love how it
GD XE is now responding X is failing it
was quick must restart do you see has a
virus our horses died no idea what
you're talking about
[ __ ] supper or toning kill it before
it lays eggs lastly with me I have Jean
from anime appraisal hey guys
oh wait I'm not ready okay um Connie
tremulous on what's up guys hey just
shut the [ __ ] up
Jimmy shut the [ __ ] up I'm sharing
screens twice let me show you
what get the [ __ ] out
no [ __ ] you Jimmy [ __ ] you people think
I'm bullying you but they don't realize
how much of a [ __ ] [ __ ] you can get
some - me - Jimmy you shut up Jimmy calm
down killer kill is not bad
[ __ ] you too Jimmy [ __ ] you sir wind
dogs don't dump BEC sucks
Oh shudders huh hold the [ __ ]
doorknob Islamic Saskia
[ __ ] Jimmy shut up what the [ __ ] are you
talking about what's your favorite
monopoly piece the car I think it's the
boot why do you get to put your foot
because I about your house the original
J taco member I was the original holding
Jimmy what do you not like Alvin answer
I'm the one people know me they don't
know you Legend of Korra right like for
atomically I know we live in doing this
you [ __ ] jackass
I know I know what I'm [ __ ] popular
to currently [ __ ] studio trigger [ __ ]
for you kiamashi [ __ ] kill your
sceneries dumbass hands [ __ ] anime [ __ ]
everything sayonara me no sound thanks
for watching [ __ ] you - Julie [ __ ] you
sir win everyone will huddle up okay
everyone have a lock we need a team
huddle really quick deep within my
Calvin Klein's I am prepared for this
play t foot team puddle of real this is
going on the Internet
people will know who you are yep and so
anything you say will always be there
mom
don't listen to this one I haven't
walked in four days so some of you may
some of you may have been led astray
from understanding the wonders of the
oppai
but let me just tell you this there is
nothing wrong with a fine bottom there's
nothing
with these wonderful buttocks that's
perfectly understandable but one needs
to understand the brilliance of the
breasts
there is nothing Lauria does you've got
like the first church Reverend Jimmy
Jimmy remember Jimmy please
praise His Holy Name let me get a
hallelujah one you just wonder stand but
where there are boobs there are no news
yes
ah who as he was once said there are
standing ovations my kept my friend was
like I'm growing hair on my areola and
I'm like I mean hair on your nips leg
he's like yeah and I'm like that's
[ __ ] up blind you know you know the
feeling where you by the beach right and
the desi girls everywhere I've been just
like it's sunglasses time any anime fan
guy with you put on sunglasses and
there's just women around to look at ya
you immediately think that you've a
Byakugan and your eyes told him when
you're staring at someone no I've been
she turns around and he quickly make eye
contact and you like [ __ ] she knows and
it's just like it's like when you
spotted the Metal Gear Solid it was the
guy who ran the real doll shop and he
looking dead into the camera he says I
feel like they're my own daughters but
when I close that door I cry
censorship in ten times and I get to
that point well I take off four times
I'm like sweating it's me pixelated just
getting ballsy you know I'm slapping the
back here is a coup we should wear
nothing for little bits of black
electrical tape on all our Johnson's and
Sam ptui my okay this is gonna be weird
but my partition that comes to two gente
is dog skin I saw that you doing what
you're wise cosmides anything's because
you're [ __ ] blush or the so Jimmy
gets his rocks too black sets in with
Sakura express her legs in is just
dripping
is going to stay to until the Sundays
yeah the great night know having a shame
the saliva 303 you saw her Bush and it
was like this moment of no beating
around I think that's a good way to end
this podcast or pie defenders I still
haven't whacked in four days
tables date that's it for me an awesome
kick up from the enemies learn and oh my
god all right this is exactly what
you're talking about that moment when
you're done and you just like the fun on
Friday this mom I'm sitting here
ringside with my best man garance and
we're here to judge the official
sparring match tristan versus jean yet
again oh my gosh what the person no this
is the [ __ ] dragon from fate/stay
night that's without a morning is no oh
my god seven eyes shut up you know Marco
is the worst [ __ ] character in this
series we are not getting into this are
you insane okay founder oh no okay well
I just washed it last night so I know
what hold on Jimmy think before you
speak pyramid it's frosty soul has
entered nine okay this is like I'm
bending over now do you wanna [ __ ] me
any more than you just said but he just
did one okay let me let me spit on my
[ __ ] really quick so it goes in easier
I'm [ __ ] bending over and you just
want to [ __ ] me in the argon sauce so no
because I told you to go not watch you
you had to go watch it and suddenly
becomes the Messire of all anime no my
god what a [ __ ] would they give you a
buzz what is this
whatever we become no you all shut them
[ __ ] off and we talked about perfect
blue I am Jack's
utter break
you haven't attempted again I'm going to
because why Dom listen not what story
listen how can you think that is good in
any kind of way is you scare me that's
goes goes goes goes goes goes soon I got
sooie sooie
36:33 like office my god I got this
doing I got this I'll leave Italy I just
love in coming up like what the [ __ ] my
help
well where did that happen okay go do I
give you credit for Kristin
you're just being a biased little rap
lovin [ __ ] I'm sorry Jimmy I'm not you
I'm giving you the [ __ ] mug [ __ ]
taken oh my god way I think my finger I
think you would I blow my [ __ ] foot
down I got to intro or [ __ ] with
Jimmy okay that's it I'm in this
I'm Minister Li ng I'm in the city M
you're not getting away with that line
you have just said don't go back to
[ __ ] your dog a cigarette Murdoch
scramble and that was go oh my god get
the [ __ ] out wow you all what what what
100 dumplings are you stupid
gggg up your mind hey someone deal with
this I'll be back [ __ ] it oh yeah hey
guys this gig I care I made this video
as my own personal final send-off to
port aku which if you didn't know was
podcast I was a partner for nearly four
years now and was a pretty big part of
my life so even though it's ending this
video encapsulates the way I wanted it
to be
remember and not the sad times that it
is now every one of you has fun [ __ ]
around with your friends and making
memories but I was actually lucky enough
to have all these moments recorded and
to be able to share it with the world
which is exactly what Pataki was so if
it's going to die this is how I want it
to be remembered just a bunch of friends
[ __ ] around on the internet that
somehow grew into something so much more
don't worry depart to my yearly rundown
is still on track for the end of this
month
so until then one last time I'd like to
say goodbye port aku it's been one hell
of a ride oh it's recording Oh